>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> We've got our next authors here.
Cynthia and Sanford Levinson are
married and have teamed up not only
in holy matrimony but
also to write a book.
Together they have written
Fault Lines in the Constitution:
The Framers, Their Fights, and
the Flaws that Affect Us Today.
As its title suggests, the book
connects true stories of the writing
of the Constitution of the United
States to real present-day issues.
The book draws upon the
knowledge of both authors.
Cynthia Levinson has written
extensively about history
and historical figures in her books
for children and young adults.
And Sanford Levinson has written
about constitutional law and history
as a lawyer and professor at the
University of Texas Law School.
My understanding is that Fault Lines
in the Constitution is
fresh off the press.
Fresh off the press, Fault Lines
in the Constitution was
published yesterday?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Yes.
That's exactly right.
>> September 1st, yesterday.
Let's give a round of
applause to our authors.
That is amazing.
[ Applause ]
I would also like to bring
to your attention to the blog
that the Levinsons wrote
to accompany Fault Lines
in the Constitution.
If you're interested in, like,
further reading, you can find it
at faultlinesintheconstitution.com.
You can also meet both of our
authors later for a book-signing.
So, and book signing --
just to remind everybody,
the book signings are
down to my left
which will be your audience right.
Without further ado,
let me introduce Cynthia
and Sanford Levinson.
[ Crowd Cheering ]
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
>> Sanford Levinson: Thank you.
[ Background Discussions ]
>> Cynthia Levinson: I
can't see where I am.
Is this? No?
OK. I have to go back one.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize that there
was -- yep, thank you.
Oh that's where it is.
OK. So our very kind
introducer just mentioned
that this book is fresh
off the press.
He also mentioned a
blog that we're doing.
We're blogging every two weeks
about this book to keep it updated.
And in keeping with that urgency --
he mentioned that it's
very current --
we have just changed this
morning our presentation for you.
We're going to include some of the
slides that we had been planning
to include but we're
beginning differently
than we had initially thought we
would because of current events.
This young woman whom you see
here is named Leezia Dahhla.
Leezia now lives in Washington, DC.
She grew up in San Antonio,
Texas, but she was born in Canada.
She came with her family to this
country when she was six years old.
She graduated from
school in San Antonio.
Northwestern University.
She got jobs.
What she didn't know was, until she
was about to graduate from college,
was that her family had overstayed
their visas in the United States.
Leezia has been living here
as an undocumented alien
since she was a senior in college.
Now we're not tattling on Leezia.
Leezia opens chapter four in
Fault Lines in the Constitution.
And the reason she does that --
and she graciously allowed us to
use her story, to tell her story --
is that her situation is very
closely related to the constitution.
What makes her story especially
urgent now and the reason we decided
to open with her is that
there is speculation
that the president is
going to end a program
that has allowed her
to stay and work here.
That is a program that
was handed down.
It was an executive order handed
down by President Obama in 2012,
the DACA program -- Deferred
Action for Children of Aliens.
But there is possibility --
the president has suggested that
he might be ending that program.
Her situation is integrally
involved in problems
with the US Constitution.
And I'm going to turn it to
Sandy to let him explain how.
>> Sanford Levinson: OK.
So how does this relate
to the constitution?
And why does this take
up a chapter in our book?
The answer goes back
to December 2010
when the House passed legislation
that would have legalized
or normalized the presence in the
United States of children brought
into the United States
by their parents
and would have given them basically
a safe haven in the United States.
Congress is bicameral and we spend
a great number of pages in our book
on the fact that Congress
consists of two separate houses.
So getting through the
House wasn't good enough.
It has to go through the Senate.
What happened in the Senate?
Well, as a matter of fact,
a majority of the Senate,
with members from both parties,
supported the so-called
Dream Act bill.
But a majority isn't good enough
thanks to Rule 22 of the Senate
that requires a super-majority
in order
for bills to come up to a vote.
So the key vote in the Senate in
December of 2010 was whether or not
to go forth with legislation.
The vote was 55 to 45.
You might think that in a country
that calls itself a democracy
that would be good
enough to go to a vote.
Well it isn't because Rule 22
says you have to have 60 votes
and 60 is more than 55, obviously.
This can be traced back to
an obscure but important part
of the constitution
that gives each house
of Congress the ability
to set its own rules.
And so one of the rules the
Senate has established is
to require a super-majority
to get a vote.
We also actually begin the
very first chapter in the book
with a story about lynching.
In 1921, Warren Harding,
a Republican president,
with the cooperation of a Republican
congressman from St. Louis,
introduced an anti-lynching
bill in the House.
It ultimately didn't pass because
of the filibuster of white,
southern Democrats in the Senate.
And this was true throughout
the next several decades.
And we still don't have a
federal anti-lynching bill,
though fortunately we either don't
have lynchings since the 1950s
or basically don't have them.
But we should have had an
anti-lynching bill in 1921
and we didn't have it
because of this same feature
of the constitution.
>> Cynthia Levinson: So both
of these are examples --
one from chapter one and
one from chapter four --
in which the majority of the
legislators and the majority
of the population wants a particular
law but for various reasons
because of entrenchment in the
constitution, they cannot pass
which is frustrating for everybody.
These are two examples
of how our book,
Fault Lines in the Constitution,
differs from other books
about the Constitution.
Most other books walk through
the Constitution in order article
by article, explaining
how our government works.
We do believe that to some large
extent our government does work.
We are not thorough-goingly
against our Constitution.
It has survived for, come September
17 of this year, 230 years.
On the other hand, there are
very, very fundamental problems
with our Constitution,
some of them having to do
with what's been there all the way
through and some of it having to do
with obsolescence which we'll
tell you a little bit about.
So our book focuses on problems
within the Constitution.
>> Sanford Levinson: Can I?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Yeah.
>> Sanford Levinson:
That many of you --
many of the parents here might
be familiar with civics courses
that talk about how
a bill becomes a law.
And one of the things that makes
our book different in some ways is
that we focus on why it is that
most bills never become laws.
And the DACA bill,
the Dream Act bill,
or the anti-lynching bill are
only two of a number of examples.
It's also true that most modern
courses on the Constitution,
especially since World War two
focus on constitutional rights.
Constitutional rights are important.
We like rights.
That being said, we also think that
it's very, very important for people
who really are going to
understand our system
to understand the structures
of government
that often make it very difficult,
in fact, to enact legislation
that would enable people to enjoy
their constitutional rights.
>> Cynthia Levinson: And
I mentioned two other ways
in which our book is different from
other books about the Constitution,
especially for young readers.
One is that we give
examples from other countries
and from state constitutions
where some of the problems
with ours are avoided
or worked around.
So we're not completely hopeless.
We provide ways to ameliorate
the situation, to improve things.
And also at the end of the
book we grade the constitution.
Spoiler alert.
It does not get an A. In fact it
doesn't even get a B. Now every sort
of, every test -- you know, a lot
of young people here take tests.
There are measures for tests.
You're tested against something.
There's an expectation.
So we have expectations
for the Constitution.
But they're not just ours.
They were the founding fathers'.
They were the Framers' expectations
which are written into the Preamble.
So here are the tests, the
measures, the standards,
and rubrics for the Constitution.
We the people of the United States,
in order to form a
more perfect union --
>> Sanford Levinson:
Establish justice.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Ensure domestic tranquility.
>> Sanford Levinson: Provide
for the common defense.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Promote the general welfare.
>> Sanford Levinson: And
secure the blessings of liberty
to ourselves and our posterity.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Do ordain
and establish this Constitution
for the United States of America.
So you might think about the
two examples we just gave
of issues in the Constitution.
How well does the Constitution
or the Preamble hold up,
given those issues and also a couple
of others we're about to talk about?
One that you are probably very
familiar with here in Washington,
DC -- we expected applause
at this point, you know?
You know? [Cheers]
Yes, that's right!
Taxation without representation!
Who wants that?
This is chapter six in Fault Lines
without -- what did we call it?
Fault Lines in the Constitution.
That's the name of
our book [laughing].
And this comes straight
out of the Constitution.
>> Sanford Levinson: Right.
Congress in fact is
required to carve
out a certain territory
for the US capital.
And those of you who might be
fans of the play Hamilton know
that it's here and not elsewhere
because of a deal that was struck
in the room where it happened
between Hamilton and Jefferson.
But Washington like Puerto Rico --
which we also discuss
briefly -- is not a state.
And that means that you have
no representation in Congress
which means that the federal
taxes that are imposed
on you you have no say in.
It also means that the local
taxes that you might have some say
in through the Washington
City Consul are ultimately
under the control of Congress.
So this really doesn't
look like what most people
in the 21st century would think
a democratic self-government is
all about.
>> Cynthia Levinson: So you'll
be glad to know that you all --
you know, those of you who
live in the district, anyway --
are well represented in this book,
even if you're not well
represented in congress.
[ Crowd Cheering ]
Thank you.
And I should thank our
son-in-law, by the way,
because he made a strong case
for including that chapter.
[Laughing]
[ Light Applause ]
So another thing that you
might not expect in a book
about the Constitution
is a graphic --
these graphics are from the
book -- about corn syrup.
Now why is there a graphic on corn
syrup in a book on the Constitution?
Well, corn syrup is
in a lot of products.
In fact, when Sandy and
I were flying down here
on American Airlines we were
handed a package of mini pretzels
and Sandy looked at the ingredients.
Yep. Corn syrup right here
in a package of pretzels.
Who needs corn syrup in pretzels?
It's in muffins.
It's in ketchup.
It's in soft drinks do corn
syrup just pervades our diet
and it's not healthy.
That's the other thing.
Corn syrup is deteriorating
Americans' health,
especially young people in fact.
It is very likely that
there are corn products
in the carpeting right here
and in the seat cushions
that you're sitting on.
Why is this the case?
This also relates to
the Constitution.
>> Sanford Levinson: Right.
The United States Senate,
as the result of what is often
called The Great Compromise --
but you should know that James
Madison detested this compromise
and described it as a lesser evil.
The decision of 1787 was
to give each state the same
voting power in the Senate.
It's very, very different from
the House of Representatives.
This means that the
states that grow corn,
although they have a very small
percentage of the population,
have significant power
in the Senate.
And because the agriculture
industry is what most senators --
whether they're Democrats
or Republicans,
it really doesn't matter.
It's -- they're representing
their constituents faithfully
and honestly.
They're sent to Washington
to get federal funds
for local agricultural
interests including corn.
So the Senate is a tribute to what
we would call malapportionment.
We like to think that we believe
in the principle one person,
one vote in this country.
We don't. And the Senate is the
best example and it has consequences
as revealed in how it is we spend
so much money on encouraging people
to grow corn and corn syrup.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Right.
And as you can see from
this graphic from the book,
less than half the population in the
United States is represented by 82%
of the Senate, whereas more
than half the population is
represented by only 18 senators.
The story which begins the chapter
in which we talk about the Senate
and this inequity tells the
story of the Patriot Act,
which gave more money per capita to
small states which had less chance
of being attacked by future
terrorist attacks than large states
like New York, Massachusetts,
California, and that sort of thing.
That chapter refers to the
upside-down math of the Patriot Act.
It's really the upside-down
math of the US Senate.
So Sandy and I wrote
this book together.
As our introducer said,
I write for young people.
He writes for older people.
>> Sanford Levinson:
Largely academics.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Yes, largely academics.
That's right.
And college and graduate students.
We wrote the book in one voice --
that is as if one person
is telling the story --
until the last chapter
where we hold a debate
with each other, going
back and forth.
And here is a picture of the
two of us recording our debate
with each other for the
audio version of the book.
The debate is about
what do we do now?
As I said, we don't
leave you hopeless.
We give you examples of
how to do things better.
And we also talk about ways
to change the Constitution.
From my perspective,
I think we should go
through the amendment
process, even though the second
to the last chapter of the book
features how, the difficulty
of amending the Constitution.
Sandy's approach, however --
>> Sanford Levinson: Yes.
Is to call for a new constitutional
convention as, in fact,
Article 5 allows but
has never been done.
In our comparative approach,
we show that almost all
other constitutions --
not only around the world.
Who really cares about other
national constitutions,
unfortunately?
But also within the United
States are easier to amend
than the US Constitution.
So if we are seriously to confront
the kinds of issues that face us,
my own view is ultimately that we
need a new constitutional convention
as envisioned by the Framers.
We do not engage in founder-bashing.
They did the best they
could in 1787.
The question raised in our book is
what we do in 2017 and the future
with regard to responding to
what we should recognize are the
fault lines.
And the title does come from
geology and the possibility
that tectonic plates that
generally you could ignore every now
and then will create
catastrophic earthquakes.
And we should try to anticipate that
before it happens rather than wait
until the catastrophe comes.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Well
I don't disagree with that.
It's just that, you know, if you
have a constitutional convention,
everything is up for grabs.
But we won't go through
the debate right now.
You can read that in there.
But I do want to go back.
We do want to go back to
-- remember the Preamble?
Here's the crib sheet on the
Preamble, you know, for the test.
So we ask you all to think
about what you think.
To what extent do you think the
Constitution meets its goals?
I see we only have
five minutes left.
We want to remind you also about
the blog as our introducer did
because we are keeping the book
updated every couple of weeks.
Do you want to add anything
before we turn it to questions?
>> Sanford Levinson: I would love
to hear some questions or comments.
>> Cynthia Levinson: So yes.
We would love to know your
thoughts about the Preamble
to the Constitution, the writing,
whatever you'd like to bring up.
It's a little hard to see.
Oh I think we must have
answered every single question.
Well wait.
No, is that somebody?
I think we have a question.
>> Sanford Levinson: Good.
>> Cynthia Levinson:
Or somebody's leaving.
I can't quite tell.
I don't want to embarrass anybody.
>> Sanford Levinson:
Nope, there is a question.
>> Cynthia Levinson: Oh, OK.
[Inaudible question]
Oh, interesting.
So the question is I
sort of gave it away
that we don't give the Constitution
an A or a B in our research.
Who or what state or other
country does get an A?
To tell you the truth, we didn't
grade other constitutions in part
because other constitutions
don't have the Preamble.
Our, you know, the US
Constitution Preamble.
And that's the measure.
Also, frankly we sort
of cherry pick.
So we don't look at other
constitutions wholesale.
We look at other aspects of other
constitutions that do a better job
in particular areas than ours does.
For instance, we have an example we
were going to use, except we decided
to talk about Leezia Dahhla instead,
about continuity of government
and what to do in habeas corpus.
It's complicated issues but
interesting to children still,
about what to do in case of
epidemics or devastating floods.
We live in Texas, so you know,
please think of the
Gulf Coast right now.
And we give an example from
the South African Constitution
which does address more effectively
than our 1787 constitution does what
to do in cases of attacks
and that sort of thing.
>> Sanford Levinson: It's also the
case that inevitably the answer
to that question is going to
be a function about what is it
that most worries you right now?
If in fact you thought the
constitution is working reasonably
well, you'd give it a B or a B plus.
And if you thought there were
ways to make it even better,
then you might focus
on say Article 5,
which makes it extraordinarily
difficult to amend the Constitution
and you might look at one
of the other constitutions
within the country or around the
world that is easier to amend.
It's no secret, though, that
today -- that is, this very day --
there is a great deal of
discussion about President Trump
and his own continuity in office.
If we had a parliamentary system,
he could be voted out of office
with a vote of no confidence.
We don't. If we were California,
then there could be
a recall election.
But we don't have that either.
>> Cynthia Levinson: And
we'll be glad to talk --
sorry, but our very patient person
is standing here giving us the
high sign.
>> Sanford Levinson: Right.
>> Cynthia Levinson: [Laughing]
But we'll be glad to talk more
about these things afterwards or,
you know, when we're signing books.
>> I just want to say --
>> Cynthia Levinson: Oh.
>> Thank you.
Because there's finally -- with
your book there's finally a book
about current issues that
relates directly to the history
of the country for us to read to
our children because the best way
to affect change is through
our children [sobbing].
As an immigrant myself -- I
know I don't look like, I mean,
I blend in with America because
I'm from Canada but I have a lot
of immigrant friends who
don't blend in the way I do
because they look different,
they sound different.
And it's a major issue for
a lot of us and thank you
for bringing that awareness
up again.
And hopefully it creates a
dialogue between American families.
So just thank you.
I appreciate that.
>> Cynthia Levinson: And thank you--
>> Sanford Levinson: Thank you.
>> Cynthia Levinson: For
your heartfelt concern.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
[ Background Discussions ]
>> More questions or?
>> Cynthia Levinson: Oh!
Do we have time?
Oh! Hello.
>> So if I was --
>> Cynthia Levinson: Sorry.
>> If I was able to wave a magic
wand and give you the opportunity
to change one thing
in the constitution,
what is it you would choose
and how would you go about it?
>> Cynthia Levinson: OK.
I've got two.
I'm sorry, Marty.
I've got two things.
One is I think, having worked
with Sandy on this book,
my two least favorite parts of the
Constitution actually are the Senate
and the electoral college.
Sandy, what about you?
>> Sanford Levinson: Well, I
mean, as I said it really a moment
or two ago, asking me this
question today given what I have
to admit, it's no secret.
You could Google me -- are my
views about President Trump.
I would prefer that there were
an alternative to impeachment
or the 25th amendment, neither
of which works effectively.
But on the other days, I might very
well give you a different answer.
I certainly agree with Cynthia
that the electoral college has
long since outlived its time.
I share James Madison's view
that the Senate is an evil
and I think it's no
longer a necessary evil.
But what concerns me most today is
the power that the president has
and the fact that there's really not
much we can do about it in contrast
with many other political
systems across the world.
And for that matter, in
several of the American states.
>> Cynthia Levinson: I
think I see more questions
but I don't know if we have time.
>> Sanford Levinson: I'll
take questions as long as --
>> Cynthia Levinson: No, no.
I'm seeing heads shaking.
No time. OK.
Come talk to us afterwards.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.